Here at VisualPolitik, we love talking about
Asia, you know probably know that by now,
right?
And we like it because we are certain that
this region has a lot to contribute to the
improvement of our world.
However, not everything is as good as it sounds.
In Asia while we can certainly see plenty
of light, there are also lots of shadows...
And the largest shadow is that, without any
doubt, that the area has become a huge powder
keg, ready to blow.
On the one hand, this area is spending more
and more in weapons.
In fact, it is expected that, by 2020, the
region will account for more than 30% of all
the world's military spending.
And, on top of that, it is also becoming a
chessboard for geopolitics.
China and India are big, emergent powers,
and with time they are demanding a larger
and larger international influence.
Putin's Russia has started to feel concerned
by the Pacific and so has the United States…
Meaning, this area is extremely important.
On the other hand, there are many disagreements
among the different countries in this region,
and it seems that lately they have been looking
for any reason to start a fight.
We can find all kinds of conflicts here: economic,
territorial, historical…
China's conflict with Vietnam here, with Japan
over there…
And then there is India; the situation of
Taiwan; and the problems between Japan and
Russia.
Not forgetting the situation in Korea…
The list just grows longer and longer...
We’re going to talk about many of these,
but today we are going to focus on the sleeping
giant…
Japan.
THE TWO NIGHTMARES OF JAPAN
Japan is the world's third largest economy.
Despite that, this country has had a modest
role in international politics in the last
few decades.
However, the situation is changing, particularly
for two reasons: China and North Korea.
First, there is the emergence of China as
a superpower.
But why does Japan care about that?
Well, basically because the emergence of China
has led to a setback in Japan's regional influence.
Further, both countries maintain a bitter
conflict over a small archipelago known as
the Senkaku Islands.
“The Senkaku Islands are abandoned, but
they are still a key area in the fishing industry,
they hold large deposits of petrol and gas,
and they also are strategic in sea trade”)
Well, take a look at this chart to see how
the military budget of both countries has
evolved in the last few years.
It will give you a better understanding of
Japan’s concern about China’s emergence.
Second, and more recently, there is is North
Korea.
Pyongyang, dear viewer, has been obsessed
for the last 20 years, about developing unconventional
war capacities, these mainly being its nuclear
capability.
For now, Korea has managed to create an atomic
bomb of 30 kilotons, which is comparable to
twice the bomb of that was used on Hiroshima.
They have also succeeded in making ballistic
missiles which can reach not only South Korea,
but also Japan.
In March 2017, North Korea launched 4 ballistic
missiles against Japan.
It was somehow successful and 3 out of 4 of
them reached Japanese waters, less than 200
miles from the coast.
Well, all of this is producing a real psychosis
in Japan:
The Japanese government itself has started
to conduct evacuation drills in the event
of a hypothetical attack and has even distributed
a detailed guide to explain how Japanese citizens
should respond to a North Korean nuclear attack.
Tokyo says that people should have about 10
minutes to react, but that might be an overestimation...
“A missile may not be detected as soon as
it leaves the launch pad.
Depending on the case, the warnings and alarms
might only sound four or five minutes before
a missile arrives.”
Osaka Mayor Hirofumi Yoshimura - JAPAN TIMES
With all this going on, we shouldn't be surprised
to find out Japan is acquiring many nuclear
shelters and equipment for purifying the air
which are designed to fight radiation as well
as poisonous gas.
“Shinzo Abe, the Japanese Prime Minister
has confirmed North Korea also has the ability
to launch sarin gas missiles” Japan Times
So, ignoring whether the North Korean threat
is real or not, the reality is that China
and North Korea are perceived as being significant
threats by Tokyo.
But… before explaining how the country is
planning to fight these threats, let’s have
a look at what has been the foundation of
their defense policy in the last few decades.
JAPAN, A PACIFIST COUNTRY
As you all know, Japan was one of the countries
which lost WWII.
As a consequence of this defeat, the country
had to to establish a constitution in 1947,
which is still in force today.
In this constitution it states that war and
the use of the force is not be be used unless
in self-defence.
“Aspiring sincerely to an international
peace based on justice and order, the Japanese
people forever renounce war as a sovereign
right of the nation […] In order to accomplish
the aim of the preceding paragraph, land,
sea, and air forces, as well as other war
potential, will never be maintained”.
Article 9 of the Japanese Constitution
This means that at first the idea was that
Japan couldn't even have an army.
The country's protection was the responsibility
of the US...
However, the Korean War and the tension suffered
during the years of the Cold War changed everything:
all of a sudden both Tokyo as well as Washington
understood it was essential to form a support
force for the American Army in case Japan
needed defence.
And that is how the Japanese Self-Defence
Forces were born.
An army whose only possible purpose is defence.
But one thing is true, formally, the US still
takes care of Japan's protection and keeps
more than 40,000 soldiers deployed in the
country, and also maintains some its largest
military bases in Japan.
This is a force which, by the way, is co-financed
by the government of Japan itself...
We could even say that Japan is the largest
spearhead of the US in Asia.
However, the new threats Japan perceives in
the region, from China and North Korea have
caused Japan to no longer be satisfied with
this protection.
So, the question now is, how is Japan responding
to these threats?
ABE´S NEW DIPLOMACY
To begin with, the Japanese Prime Minister,
Shinzo Abe has started an unusual diplomatic
race to work against the growing influence
of China.
For now, he has managed to improve the country’s
relations with South Korea, to strengthen
its bonds with the US, and even bridge the
gap existing with Putin’s Russia.
Japan maintains an intense dispute over the
sovereignty of a small archipelago known as
the Kuril Islands which are now under Russian
sovereignty.
In fact, the diplomacy Abe has started is
so intense the country is now competing with
China in Africa.
(“Japan and China compete for African markets”
East Asia Forum)
And, as a curious fact, Shinzo Abe was also
the first international leader to meet with
Trump in the famous residence the American
president owns in Florida.
It seems like, after this encounter, Abe managed
to win over the President and make him forget
all the attacks he made against Japan when
he was still a candidate for the Presidency.
Because, one thing is true, Trump complained
quite a lot about Japan… but things can
change.
(“We are committed to the security of Japan
and all areas under its administrative control.
(..) The friendship between our two peoples
runs very, very deep.”
Donald Trump.)
But of course, diplomacy is not always enough…
Japan’s Rearming?
And so, we finally reach the key point.
The Japan Self-Defence Forces are often thought
of as some sort of small band of men…
But, really, nothing is further from the truth.
The Japanese army is larger than the army
of France and the UK combined!
It is true that, given their name, we may
not think they are important, but the abilities
and capacity of this strange army are impressive.
For many analysts, they are still the best
army in Asia…
Although China certainly competes for that
top spot.
And look, Japan´s investment in defense is
quite low, at less than 1% of its GDP, but
that is still a LOT of money!
Take a look at this: in 2016, Japan was the
country with the 7th highest spendon defence.
In 2017, the government will give the forces
the largest budget in its history, more than
5 trillion yens, which is around 45 US billion
dollar.
And, of course, such a quantity in such a
small and, by the way, very well trained army,
is enough for them to acquire some of the
most modern systems available...
Like the F35; the best American drones; the
Izumo class aircraft carriers or even the
new fifth generation fighter jet from (which
Mitsubishi is developing).
“Japan reveals the prototype of its last
furtive fighters” RT
The thing is that, since Abe became Prime
Minister in 2012, he has had the clear idea
of leaving behind the pacifist character set
by the Japanese constitution.
And this has happened:
In 2014, the Japanese government decided to
stop all restrictions on the export of warfare
material, with the goal of starting a new
Japanese military industry.
A bit later, in 2015, Abe also led a reform
so that the Self-Defence Forces could operate
abroad and today they even have a military
base in Djibouti.
And, of course, the military budget has increased
again after many years of budget cuts.
But, not only this…
They are even thinking about changing the
constitution.
(“The radical military shift of Japan echoes
the ghosts of World War II”.
BBC)
So, What do you think?
Should Japan leave its pacifism aside?
Should Japan give in to Beijing?
Which country seems like a better ally for
you: Japan or China?
Please leave your answers in the comments
and click like if you enjoyed this video.
Also don’t forget to check out RECONSIDER
MEDIA.COM, the podcast where you can hear
the voice on this video that isn’t mine!
And don’t forget to subscribe for brand
new videos every Monday and Thursday, and
as always, I’ll see you in the next video!